okay let's go to our caller from the
five-30 area code we are taking calls at
6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 who's calling today
from 5 3 0 hi David this is oz from
Mount Shasta hey oz what's going on
ok first I just wanted to apologize for
I have a drinking problem and I was
listening to your clip from The New
Yorker guys the landscaper the drunk guy
and I just I quit drinking it's been 2
months and I've been fighting for two
years to get 2 months sober
last summer I drank a lot and I
sometimes I call and or just leave
trolling comments that were just stupid
I'm sorry about that you were leaving
guys want to apologize but for us like
on the voicemail line hey I call them
what some messages on the voicemail and
God bless them some troll messages on
your youtube and they just you know I
drink I kind of get schizophrenic and I
don't make much sense it's just a
condition I have I'm a disabled Marine
Corps veteran and I have some other
issues but I'm working through them now
and I'm doing a lot better but I well
that's hard to hear and congratulations
on two months I want I wanted to give an
opinion and kind of a alternative idea
about something that I never really hear
anybody talk about okay and that's the
that's the second amendment and I've
been reading some alternative
interpretations of it and to me it makes
more sense that it was it actually means
the well-regulated militia it actually
means that we're not supposed to have a
standing army and we're supposed to have
more of a Swiss style military like a
militia basically not and that doesn't
mean a bunch of skinheads plan Rambo on
the weekend that means basic basic
citizens are armed and trained but
they're not standing offensive Oh
military right and so if it's and then
another thing I wanted to say real quick
is that instead of instead of taxing
people's income you know to pay for
Medicare for all
works why don't we talk about national
rising natural resources and cutting our
military spending and using that to pay
for public works because if we did that
we wouldn't have to tax people's income
and I'm out there so I don't know that
we'd not have to tax people's income at
all but I think what you're suggesting
is something along the lines of what
Alaska has done where the oil resources
part of those profits are then
redistributed to Alaskans just for
living in Alaska is that sort of the
idea I got one one other thing that's
kind of sounds crazy but I think we
should colonize Antarctica and turn it
into a battery an energy battery because
they have the highest wind in the world
and just a wind of the power the
harnessing of the wind there alone and
half a year they have Sun and the
hydroelectric factor of all the I of
melting ice could be harnessed and tidal
energy can be harnessed
you could turn an ark into a battery
just I've just thought all right Thank
You great to hear from you interesting
ideas and glad you are two months sober
let's let's make it three before we know
it really appreciate the call thank you
so much